hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and it's John here so we're going to
continue our parts of the Caribbean film
franchise retro review series this week
continuing with part two Dead Man's
Chest okay okay so John how many times
did you see this movie uh
I thought a couple times in the theaters
and then I want to see how to see I want
to say is you know like three or four
times yeah we these retro reviews a
little bit different it's more just
freeform flowing thoughts on the film as
opposed to you know breaking it down
yeah yeah just as a heads up more about
experience than it is you know book
provoking as I've been talking here
chances are you've seen it already and
in many years it was decision-making
time that's long since passed I saw this
film twice in the theaters I remember
the first time I watched it I did not
like it I really didn't like it and it
was one of those movies where I remember
one day I was I was like taking a very I
used to walked everywhere at that time I
was still a teenager then so I used to
just walk like miles to get places or
take the bus and I was like thinking
about the film and then I started
thinking like yeah there's some cool
stuff in it it's pretty cool it might be
better than the first one actually
hasn't said then I watched it again the
second thousand like and now I got to
just find out if I really like this film
or not and I loved it the second time I
watched it and ever every time I watch
it ever since then I really do enjoy the
film a lot and the reason I'm bringing
that up is because I feel like this is
one of those films that it gets a lot is
supposedly like Windows in French I
began to decline but I think it's part
two I could totally see I could totally
see it I I don't think it's as bad as a
lot of people have made it out to be you
know I even look at the rod tomato score
like 54 percent and my nods way better
than a 54 and and in some ways I think
they're aspects of it that
better than the first I don't think
overall an overall film it's as strong
as the first one but I think in a lot in
most ways I'd say the majority is it's
just as good as the first one at least
in terms of values and imagination and
adventure attack you're right I mean
there are a lot of I feel like the
Pirates 2 is a little more intermittent
than the first one like there are times
where I'm like oh yes a bit longer like
I I see why we got to do this but you
know these plot points are getting kind
of stretched out but I remember liking
this movie pretty much the first time I
saw it I mean I liked it and then I came
to appreciate more stuff later I thought
is it long I think I was the only
complaint I at first time was it was you
know a bit well especially that finale
the finale of this film is very long
because they go to the island where they
finally retrieve Davy Jones's the chest
that they've been looking for this whole
movie and they break into a three
mansoor five which is very entertaining
and then Davy Jones people show up on
the island and they Keira Knightley's
fighting with the other two henchmen
dudes and and then and then after that
then they're on the ship where David
Jones is attacking them with what's the
ship called the Flying Dutchman the
Flying Dutchman and they get up a little
bit further away so then the Kraken
starts attacking him it's just the super
long finale however as it was playing
out whenever I caught myself either
feeling a little exhausted or a tad bit
bored or drained by the fact that
there's is non-stop action for like the
last 30 40 minutes of the film I found
myself also thinking well where else
would it get like this actually makes
sense that it would all be playing out
like this yeah I feel like that the
first two movies are the plotting
usually seems pretty sensical and their
times were yeah it's like there are
times where it is a bit bloated but at
the same time you understand where the
carrot like that when they're all sword
fighting each other at the same time
they're all having this like
dick-measuring contest about the chest
like yeah I get that like I get how
those characters they all have the right
motives to fight each other I thought
yeah feuding ever really felt clunky I
mean like it's it's you know you're
jumping back in to this world
the movie does start a lot faster and it
is kind of long because there's a lot of
stuff that has to achieve and I think
those things kind of turned people off
maybe but well one thing I were you know
what I thought it went when the movie
started a thought of BBS because because
you know how when we saw the show those
for BBS everyone thought like other
they're addressing the concern the issue
of all the destruction that happened and
if you watch our curse of the Black
Pearl review what we talked about was
the ending of the first one how it was
rather weak and it didn't make much
sense that they would just let them let
Jack Sparrow go and Lendl blooms off the
hook and I was like all right I
understand you for there and I like how
the opening of the film starts off with
this new character Beckett arresting
Keira Knightley and Orlando Bloom it has
a warrant out for the the Commodores
advisory room as well for that specific
ending that happened in part one because
then the whole plot really revolves it
kicks off with that and it's very
pertinent to the rest of the journey and
I appreciated the fact that you know the
writers were like well you know there's
something kind of off of you ending a
part one and it greatly affects and
leads into this whole journey of part
two in it it's things like that that I
really appreciated about the film and I
thought the cinematography I mean the
person's already shot brilliantly but
the cinematography here is a this is a
lot darker it just looks darker from
beginning and it starts off in the
pouring Thunder is written well times
are soft like with with the remnants of
like a nice hearty fine china like
clearly this is a somber occasion that
wasn't supposed to go this way I think
what we said was after now that we're
older and we've seen more this directors
work we said that this is more of a Gore
Verbinski film than the first one yeah
he gets to go all-out yeah with this
movie especially with the designs man
yeah because I thought like the first
half of this movie I actually enjoy more
than the last half and the first half of
this movie what I liked about it was
while the first half was still darker
than the entirety of the first movie it
still had a humor throughout it it was
really the last half of this
where a lot of the humor is just not
really present for majority of the last
half of the film yeah which would say
see an energy down that's where I
thought these if fun goes down even
though it's an action-packed brilliantly
choreographed and staged finale because
even like a 3-man horrified that had
some pretty cool [ __ ] ridiculous and
cheeses and their that giant wheel
barrel it's still really in a boy or
whatever temple yeah and a lot of it
look real - yeah at times you're like is
that stuntman actually like rolling at
times you can tell it's CGI but at times
it looks like it's done that yes and
it's it's but it also that's the thing
though it always made sense to me why it
went darker because Davy Jones is talked
about throughout the film
but yeah Bill Nighy he doesn't come into
the film until rather mid point or
something like that yeah it takes a
while in the beginning of the last half
of the film yeah and by the time he
shows up that's when the film gets a lot
darker but it also made sense because
I'm like yeah this is the dark romantic
version of Davy Jones and it made sense
that it would kind of stay dark and the
only one really cracking jokes is Jack
Sparrow at times well because I mean
Davy Jones is like that that's you're
Hades for pirates you know yeah this is
welcome to hell and you know I got so
yeah like I I don't fault this movie at
all for getting darker necessarily I
mean like yeah yeah I like it and I like
a lot of their ideas and like I said
that is not like his whole like
everything aboard the Flying Dutchman is
kind of great to me like the whole idea
that his crew or a mast of these damned
guys who really I'm melded with sea
creatures and stuff like especially
taking like a timeless idea like that
and putting a visual on it I thought
they did a tremendous job of that
because it would be easy to to mess that
up or to go too big and even though
they're all effects I feel like yeah
like that are cool idea though
engrossing and it's not CGI distracting
because when we were watching what they
need to it feels like it yeah in these
movies but in terms of like the close of
solid design
especially a V Jones and I felt that's
probably why the cinematography just was
dark or not in certain I mean a yapper
story telling purposes would be to help
balance out the visual effects because a
lot of the times when you have like
really high octane CGI what tends to
help is darkening the cinematography a
little bit the lighting balance always I
noticed that with a lot of movies
especially sequels that have CGI in it
yeah I mean it's knowing knowing where
to set things and how do I not
necessarily just making them darker how
to light them and then the air to put
the focus and stuff and yet like because
you'll see that like those shots or the
end of the Kratt like when the Kraken
Mouse comes up you're like ah boom yes
this is a bright day yeah a little it'll
look a little like a Miss yeah
so so I do think that yeah keeping up
dark but I remember at the time in the
theaters that [ __ ] was pretty scary well
yeah I was scared like into theatres
like special when you finally see the
Krakens mouth and it roars that was
terrifying in the theaters well I
imagine it probably read better because
when we were watching the first one
there were times when we would go oh
adds added CG yeah I'm like there were
things that I didn't realize the first
time so I feel like CG has come far
enough that what may have looked good
back then yes now you can tell you know
what Davy Jones still working on Phil
Knight yeah John I were talking when the
song was number like man I times it it's
like the close-ups looked like practical
effects
I was sold that it was a library of
practical and CGI and then we looked up
photos and it's all CGI but I eyes on
they may have done some hybrid so like I
only found photos from two scenes so
like you know if somebody else knows you
know perhaps correct this but yeah
regarde looks it looks amazing it looks
today it looks good especially out
especially there's stuff like right up
and down all that way stuff yeah looks
moist it looks like like a silicone a
plane yeah I want to say like it looks
really great and that's these are very
textural movies and I feel like it's
something that they usually get right
and I thought in terms of expanding
because though the thing with this movie
is it get so long more to the mystical
aspects then and over to a third one
which is up yet to see man I'll be an
interesting reviews kind of not looking
for watching um but the but but in the
third one when he gets incredibly
mystical here they introduce those
mystical elements even a lot more than
the first one and I telling you like
this is one of those sequels that it
works better around the second time I
think you watch it it's like in her
third time whatever and all those
elements I really did enjoy it here
because like all the stuff at the flying
dutchman was great I really liked all
the stuff with you know I expand
expanding on things that when you watch
the firt because when we watch the first
one I was aware of all the plot element
changes in the second one which make me
wonder how tied in it was for example
Jack Jack Sparrow's compass and the
first one how it doesn't point north but
the first one never establishes that it
points to what his heart desires
and and then when you look back at the
first one here I watch and I go oh is
that what it's doing because I don't
think I'm watching scenes I'm thinking
it was already part of its world they
add this in the second one because there
was no real explanation for why the end
point north or whatever but I love that
element were fascinating about it yeah
and and I really like the element of him
of how Jack spurge has no idea what he
wants so he becomes reliant on I'm going
to give it to a lot of limb for a second
I'm gonna hand this off to Keira
Knightley person I can think like that
well everyone he'll and he works them up
you know it he had to plan what they
wanted the company I'm really kick in
and that was something that I picked up
a lot more this time those more I guess
you know some of those plot elements
that maybe went over my head or got lost
in the frenzy of oh my god new part yeah
I'm like yeah I thought that was
actually particularly cool that plot
point where he's like winding up
Elizabeth to get the company I reckon
was clever no he's a creep
I thought the writing of Jack Sparrow
was still really good granted the best
way to say it is what it says in the in
the consensus score bronze man is
actually was the unpredictability of
Jack Sparrow is not as strong here
however
he's still really good in the movie Jack
Sparrow still the best most entertaining
part and has the funny and has some
really funny moments in the film yeah I
love when he goes to see who's the
character that Naomi Harris plays Tia
Dalma when you got the GTO dama shoots
the monkey yeah and on dead monkey yeah
that's what I do I get why people
receive this movie differently is
watching them back-to-back yeah I
realized that the difference to me this
is that there is a lot of humor and
there are some moments that still made
me like really loud but the britons the
first movie that I feel like the
difference here is that the first movie
has a much more even distribution of
like here's a fun character moment
here's some jokes here's a fight here
you know I didn't kind of oscillate
through those words and this one there's
like a joke here and then we're going to
go on for a while there's maybe yet
every I like so at times even the wacky
stuff like the cartoony kind of humor
because in the first one any cartoon any
kind of humor is totally works
here there are times where it seems a
bit off especially in the laptop when it
comes in there a couple of times because
the movie is a much more somber more
serious tone throughout that when the
wacky the cartoony kind of humor
happened it's a little bit thrown off
but were you watching this again even
some of the wacky there were wacky stuff
that I did enjoy the whole I love when
they go all out with like the pirates
world like the pirate it's not the
mystical stuff but just pirate stuff
like when they're in Tortuga and then
the bar fight breaks out the first
couple times I've seen that team I
didn't like it I honestly thought it
would have felt misplaced and out of
town then watching it this time I really
liked that scene I appreciated it
because it fits with what's going on at
that time well yeah and also just a
little detail like that one guy gets
whacked and then immediately there I
just punches the mic which is you know
like these these movies especially for
me to thrive on little details yeah bad
and this film is still full of those oh
you thought like and that's something
that I appreciate and going back to tada
Mattoon and
Hera's I love her she's so lucky shirt
as that character like I don't like Jack
Sparrow in the sense that she's weirdly
sexy
Vidia yeah what is he's got that thick
accent and actually like the first time
I thought it I think I just plumb didn't
pick it up and this time I was like I
understand exactly how this accent works
now so I guess I really understand what
you're saying but uh I really liked the
addition of that character and I only
time you go to like a creepy Bayou good
for me yeah yeah now and I'm going back
to Tortuga I really like who the who's
the actor that plays of the Commodore
Jack Davenport MTV's smash ah okay now a
little Marilyn Monroe Oh Jack Davenport
well he's a decent character in the
first one he's really the character is
not rooting for it really just kind of
an inconvenience you should just
understand what's going on yeah yeah
playing that that yeah
stuck-up royal guy I think he doesn't I
think he doesn't I'm not really good for
what the role was in the first one I
loved how they changed his character in
this he's got the facial hair he's down
in the dumps a no he hates his life I'm
so proper in general yeah he's gritty
I like the turn he has you know where he
because his plot motivation makes sense
to steal the papers and also you know
return the heart so he can get it back
his life all that was making a lot of
sense to me and I really like his
character in this one more than I did
the first one is the evolution of that I
like a lot
he was definitely one of the surprises
for me the first time and and I just
enjoyed him that much more this time
when he comes back I was like hmm and
I'm always happy for actors like that
when they get to reprise the role but do
something real differently I like have a
chance to spread their wings a little
bit in a sequel or something like that
before I forget this point I I just
really love Bill Nighy as Davy Jones Oh
loving fantastic yeah he's a great
choice he's a different type of villain
cuz he's not the fun villain kind of the
way he'll are but he's got more Bosa
because Barbosa and Jack have a very
civic dynamic in chemistry and
protagonist antagonist dynamic happening
in the first one and this one he is evil
and cunning and he has every right to
chew up the scenery because of the
designs and everything but his
performance is great he's really scary
and he is the kind of villain where
you're like how will you beat this guy
yeah yeah or even if you can see how
it's like the stakes still seemed
enormous a lot of things have to go
right yeah yeah and yeah he's hurt like
down to his little mannerisms that all
come through the CG if there was makeup
through the makeup like he's used to
chew up scenery but but ironically I
really not I don't think that back yeah
he's not easy I feel like a right level
because I've seen bill 9 you show up and
stuff where I'm like yeah he's like an i
Frankenstein and I was like yeah yeah
need to be here and like you really are
chewing on the underworld
yeah like this is like yeah he's a big
crazy-looking thing but like man his
performance made it that much more
believable I can't imagine anybody else
doing what he did or you know and and
getting to see that that character is
really gratifying and is the memorable
you got it
especially now Marvel movies never
really Oh villains like Barbosa great
villain Davy Jones awesome villain I
like a good step up from them yeah like
we got to do bigger and scarier for a
second bill and he totally tops it yeah
and that's one of the things that I
think the second movie like really just
just nailed yeah like knowing no matter
you can you can only go around and be
like oh you know maybe the first one but
that's like I would still want the
second one oh yeah all that oh yeah for
all that extra stuff the thing is like
even if it yeah even if it is a bit more
somber a bit more dark a bit you know
lengthier you got to invest harder in
this man there are so so many great
moments and so many great details and so
many great ideas and designs and like
there's a lot of great stuff going on
stellan skarsgård no sorry speaking of
Marvel's to the star chart in
a bootstrap bill that relationship man I
fell for him I need help for him the guy
just had like the worst luck and he's
always trying to do the right thing for
someone they play that gambling game and
then he bets his life to be on for
eternity I bet says eternity to be on
the flying dutchman yeah and then he
learns from Orlando Bloom crew I'm a
cheetah hey but hey learn so you just
wanted to know where the key what's that
like a heartbreak in his eyes this is
terrible like loss and just trying to do
the right thing for his son because he
brought the thing about Orlando Bloom
that wasn't as charming as the first one
he didn't engage me and I don't know one
plot for me because the plot they give
him is he's just men on a mission in
this one what his dialogue isn't as
interesting and we already know who is
you know I I did you learn the writing I
think for him because I thought all the
other layers were still there yeah and I
brought to a darker place to be find
that his dad's alive being held captive
and I kind of like the arrogant side
that comes out of him in the finale of
ice gotta kill Davy Jones cuz I got a
rescue my dad and he's like any doesn't
like Jack anymore he knows Jack just
rights and training his life I I love I
love that dynamic because you're not
even Keira Knightley can distract him
from his goal see ya I liked oddly
enough
I like I like pretty much everybody in
this movie Keira Knightley and Orlando
Bloom left less of an impression on me
in this movie I feel like they got
better as time went on I think Orlando
Bloom is probably best when he's in
those scenes with stellan skarsgård you
know like yeah the father-son teens are
my favorites really real character stuff
to do
yeah and then everything after that like
I get it although healing I like I like
when he is becoming when he when he does
his best to lead the pirate ship you
know when Janet will lead at the Black
Pearl for a while and he becomes like
leader of taking down the Kraken I
thought that I thought he did a really
good job there I like that
evolution and becoming the leader of the
pirates yeah and in that specific moment
anything you don't even like that cheesy
ass moment where Jack shows up at the
end and
these are the shotgun to shoot the
barrels to get the crowd go away a good
prettier jack yeah like that moment to
want and I didn't like it the first few
times I saw and keira knightley makes
out with Jack at the end I never really
liked that moment but this time around I
thought watching the whole film again I
thought it built up to that reasonably
well they keep hinting in it as a
compass keeps pointing to Jack and then
just from knowing the first one how
drawn a pirate she is and Jack is the
most authentic of the Pirates it made
sense to me this time around that she
was drawn to Jack see how I guess I
would have to watch it again because I
had that same thing of like when they
brought in that whole thing of that
whole plot point about Elizabeth
suddenly being attracted to Jack it
started to come together a little bit
for me later I started to understand
what it was for but when it first popped
up even this time I like what I really
like they her it will seem like they're
really old about each other they did
before there's nothing in the first
movie that really hints that there isn't
there isn't yeah yeah yeah and just
jumping in here I guess like that
something that's kind of a drawback to
me about jumping and so fast is that the
adventure kind of begins and then by the
time it gets that I'm like oh wait but
where were you at with will how is this
happening
and then I do think at least as my
recollection goes from from watching it
yesterday that I really liked how they
played the moment when she kisses him
and walks him up and all that I figure
what that spoor is good I got a little
muddy on what the actual context was
like if her attraction to haven't
stopped a long time ago and now she's
just using this as a strategy or if
she's still wondering or maybe she's not
still wondering the compass is pointing
all over my plate I thought it was a
goodbye kiss for Jack but this time
watching it around because because even
as she's talking to him and had
handcuffs she doesn't step away start
giving some speech she's like still
really close to him and looks tempted to
Eve to kiss him even more so in that
moment I thought because and it seems
like she was regretting like she was
feeling bad like this is the only way to
stop the cracking I don't want to do
this uh have to I guess I didn't get any
affection in that look I got this is
what we have to do it wants you destroy
what I need to do I didn't get like a uh
like I guess I got the history I got the
like oh we like this hath to suck
somehow because I'm sending you
offensively to your death you know in
the horrible way see I felt that way the
first few times but this time around I
actually I don't know there's something
in the body wounds of how close she was
to his face actually always look like
she was about to kiss him some more and
I felt there were threads and she's like
crying at the end about it I believed
that stuff I just don't again like I
don't know if I buy that it comes from
like I love you as you love him or or
yeah like I want to be with you maybe
like I'm sad this this romance might be
I didn't read any romance in it but I
didn't read history I didn't really like
we've been we've been risking our lives
because her you know I dubious
circumstances but like yeah I mean I
definitely bought that she would be
broken up about it you know later
especially when they're all together and
and everyone's feeling a little icky a
little hot at the end you know
regardless that whole sequence I thought
was shot really well when they're all
getting away from the Pearl and Jax
trying to get out and then he decides to
just meet his fate head-on yeah I like
how we get them hat back yeah little
touches okay yeah
it had to have the whole boot use the
Krakken took it earlier and also that
that ending with Barbosa coming at the
end that's exciting to me and I love
that he finally ate his [ __ ] Apple oh
yeah I wanted a whole movies about that
he just wants to eat a damn Apple and he
eats a lot of years like oh he's alive
he's alive you know he's not just a
undead being again yeah lie and say I
really do like that touch they'd even
Gore Verbinski's slight touch because
when you watch the movie again when you
go to Naomi Harris's place there is like
a 1 second shot where you see the monkey
like tugging on his leg or something the
bodies laying down yeah easy you see
feet it's their eluting that he's there
but I don't think the first time you
watch it they are like oh it's
definitely Barbosa did you know no in
fact I forgot how they orchestrated that
so at first when I saw his feet up like
oh is it about to happen already oh yeah
I forgot that they left it until the
very end and yeah that was a man like
that's still a fun cliffhanger yeah I'm
still really happy I want to watch it
thoroughly
yeah yeah like that last shot you know
it's so awesome he comes down the stairs
you know what's what's happened would
become of my ship yeah like it man oh
it's such a great button even if it's
even if it's a time you might be like
what is happening he died
thank you no yeah I know it's a great
it's and I think that this is a good
chapter in the franchise I think it's
definitely I think the first two are
damn good movies I would say this a
great movie I think it's really cool and
great I'm going to say that and on the
internet that said the most popular
opinion about the second one I think
it's a great movie Jack Sparrow is
really good yes it's not it's strong
it's lengthy it kind of drags on at
times and some it's not as fun overall
but what I think what am i lacking like
you know Hollywood blockbuster fun it
makes up for dark spectacle at times
yeah an unbridled imagination the thing
is ego is full of imagination just hey
despite some of those things that you
and that our need of drawbacks for some
people that make the movie a little less
magical and a little less just
effortlessly enjoyable as the first one
and the first one even you know has some
dread bits you know I feel like this
movie not having seen the later sequels
I definitely don't think you you can
just cast it off because there is even
if it doesn't come together to be as
cohesive as a whole the first one
there's still tons of filmmaking awesome
spectacle awesome directions that they
decided to take the story and it seems
like they put a lot of thought into this
and I there's so much to appreciate even
if it's not 100% and I don't know only
other complaint I have is how in the
first like 40 minutes of the film every
few minutes there's a thing that happens
where it's like we were this funny thing
from the Bursar's boy I never had this
was buddy in the first one never the
callback it's a personal laughter like I
blew this how much Enterprise got the
candle off the wall quarter the new
bloom dude gotta love gotta love sequel
nod yeah
sequel nods are great yeah go back yeah
I always there so I get this a 50 grand
um I give it five built nineties five
Naomi Harris's and and three Orlando
Bloom that's pretty high for us pretty
high that's all very high rate if you
know our rating system that's very hot
yeah so it's only a 14 point ratings
yeah so mine was you know thirteen point
nine must the great about thirteen point
five yeah yeah your rating systems like
out of fifty five points so like 50 out
of 50 five holy holy [ __ ] is great
alright guys we're going to watch
product of the Caribbean three whole boy
you know I'm hoping that this'll
probably my fourth time watching this
movie really I'm hoping because any time
you watch one two maybe you'll get to
the pigs
I have an odd oh man I just every time I
watch it's just a dreadful experience
nah dude I just can't stand it a fifth
time it's gonna be this hoax or finally
clicks and when I can't dude it I'm not
going to go in to hate it I'm actually
hoping I go in like I'm hoping a light
go there like I said with part 2 there
were scenes that I didn't like prior
watching it last night and then watching
it now like you know I actually really
liked this scene a lot the benefit of
time a bit of time yeah hey because it
leads for me like I said it's I've seen
at least the first two films multiple
times this is the first time in at least
several years that I've actually sat
down yeah so some stuff does does sneak
up on you all right guys well you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell John that John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram social
media manager of Blum House comm go
check out our exclusive rewards at
patreon do yourself a favor and hop on
board the patreon community even for
just a dollar we got a lot to offer
believe it or not I'm talking exclusive
videos just for you folks out there much
love to everyone
good bye